so far the Marvel Cinematic Universe
piston is unstoppable as a juggernaut of
course that has to be filled with a
lowercase J because the x-men villain
juggernaut is one of the many characters
Marvel Studios doesn't currently own the
right to losing juggernaut isn't a big
deal but there are some major
superheroes Marvel Studios desperately
wishes they could include in their film
here's a look at some of the big name
superhero of Marvel Studios can't use
Professor X Professor Charles Xavier is
one of Marvel's biggest characters but
thanks to the success of 20th Century
Fox's x-men franchise he's off-limits to
Marvel Studios for the foreseeable
future which is too bad because in the
comics he plays a much larger role than
simply mentoring the x-men as a member
of Marvel's Illuminati he helps shape
events that affect the entire world and
he's been known to help out the Avengers
from time to time as well not to mention
all the times his goals come into
conflict with the plans of the other
superheroes or when he straight-up
becomes a villain alas unless Hugh
Jackman can jump back in time and change
some key contract deals it looks like
Xavier will never be able to play in the
MCU sandbox Deadpool Marvel has been in
a weird position for years now naturally
the company wants movies featuring its
characters to succeed and become popular
but in order to get the rights back they
actually need those films to flop which
would compel the rights holders to sell
those characters back without
permanently damaging the brand that's
how they eventually brought Punisher
Ghost Rider and daredevil back into the
Marvel Studios fold
Oh God but any hopes of getting Deadpool
back were dashed in 2015 when Fox's
cheeky r-rated superhero comedy starring
Ryan Reynolds became an international
blockbuster interestingly one of the
best aspects of the movie was his
hilarious interplay with members of the
x-men imagine if he were in the MCU and
could rip with Iron Man Captain America
and the rest of the Avengers
not to mention spider-man you'll have to
imagine it though because Fox made so
much money off Deadpool there's little
chance you'll see him anywhere near
Marvel Studios for years to come whoa
superhero landing Wolverine the whole
state of both the Marvel Cinematic
Universe and Fox's x-men franchise
turned on a whim of fate involving a
very unlikely figure actor Dougray Scott
most fans probably don't recall but when
the first x-men film was gearing up for
filming in the late 90s it was Scott who
was actually cast as Wolverines not Hugh
Jackman unfortunately for him he had a
schedule conflict with mission
impossible sue and had to drop out of
the film leading Fox to instead offer up
the role to Hugh Jackman we'll never
know what might have happened if Scott
had played Wolverine but we do know that
the x-men franchise has written the back
of Jackman stardom for the past two
decades Rogan is Jasmine's 9th film as
Wolverine and if he is to be believed it
will be his last
but even if he never suits up as
Wolverine again his legacy is secure and
part of that legacy is the fact that his
massive popularity has ensured that
pretty much none of the characters in
the x-men universe will be returning
from Marvel Studios any time soon mr.
fantastic dr. Reed Richards is a man of
science so he doesn't believe in
superstition but it certainly seems like
some kind of curse has fallen on the
cinematic Fantastic Four after two
relatively lackluster films from Fox the
key received a cinematic reboot in 2015
that was both a critical and commercial
bomb that film's failure fueled rumors
that Fox and Marvel had secretly cut a
deal to return the Fantastic Four film
rights to Marvel Studios both sides
denied it happen but you can't blame
fans for dreaming after all mr.
fantastic has played a key role in
almost every single major Marvel Comics
event ever and is a natural counterpart
to envy use big brains Tony Stark and
Bruce Banner and considering Fox clearly
doesn't know how to handle the character
getting him back where he belongs just
makes sense Silver Surfer as films
oversaw and the Fantastic Four sequel
for Silver Surfer is an alien who was
empowered by the world eating Galactus
but rebelled and chose to become a hero
he's a perfect fit for the MCU cosmic
side possibly fighting alongside the
guardians of the galaxy against threats
such as Fano for Ronan or he would be if
Marvel Studios could use him but since
they can't there will simply be a
surfboard shaped hole in space where he
should be
bummer the rest of the x-men and the FF
Wolverine Professor X and mr. fantastic
might be the biggest characters Fox has
the right to but of course there are
dozens if not hundreds more the rest of
the x-men and the Fantastic Four would
certainly fit in perfectly in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe alongside teens like
the Avengers the defenders and the
guardians of the galaxy and something
like the infinity war event would be the
perfect place to bring everyone together
but as long as Fox is able to keep
making money with its x-men films though
it's unlikely Marvel Studios will get
the chance to play with their own toys
and that means the biggest losers aren't
the folks at either fox or marvel's let
the fans pretty crushed out thanks for
watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love to